only one show is invited inside the
star's most epic sanctuaries welcome to
entertainment tonight everybody and
happy thanksgiving to you oh we're
making some house calls and we begin in
miami at the place that alex rodriguez
gets away from it all
[Music]
things happen and i think what happens
kev is people don't focus on all the
positives
just 48 hours after jlo unfollowed and
deleted nearly every trace of a-rod on
instagram the 46-year-old told me he's
happy and ready to move on i'm so
grateful for it i mean i had
five years of of an incredible
life and and partnership and also with
my daughters we learned so much and now
we have an opportunity to take that and
move forward and say you know what we're
so grateful for the last five years how
do we make the next five years better
because of lessons learned
you had an epic birthday
it was a long one a long one how how was
it it was awesome we rented out a boat
and and then we went down to a bees and
we kind of just kind of hopped in we
rented out a boat yeah it was like a
mega yacht it was cool and my favorite
thing i had a slide because at the end
of the day we're all little kids right
[Music]
the paparazzi followed what was that
like it was crazy
they were everywhere we enjoyed it we
had fun you know terry judo would always
tell me if you don't want to be in the
news
keep your ass at home
these are my three mvp trophies now the
yankee superstar is back at home showing
me around his miami mansion which
surprisingly has very little sports
memorabilia we never get to show this to
anybody a trophy 2009 well what i love
is it's between your two enemies yeah i
don't even know how they gave me those
but i'll take them i'll take them
a-rod's estimated worth 400 million
thanks to his mlb career investments and
endorsements he's the first latino
majority owner of an mba team the
minnesota timberwolves and he's proud of
his newest venture
president is more than a beer it's a
mindset as co-owner of presidente beer
a-rod's paying it forward heading up
their new campaign which encourages
business owners to conquer their
industry anybody can be president
anybody can be president absolutely it's
more than just a drink it's about
helping the next level hopefully i can
open the doors for other people of color
minorities latinos women and help out
you know the next generation of
entrepreneurs how are the girls doing
because last time i saw them was at the
super bowl when um your daughter tried
to take my job yeah yeah it's pretty
cool
i'll just take over from here thank you
natasha and i are doing fantastic they
rag on my social media 24 7 and they're
telling me dad like we're teenagers now
we're gonna get like crushed at school
you got to stop doing all that goofy
stuff
[Music]
next goal i think my number one goal in
life is to raise
two beautiful girls with high
self-esteem and to be a present father
there's nothing going to compare to that
as far as business goals i just hope
that i continue to evolve seven eight
years in therapy i always say to people
i'm a work in progress and it's okay to
ask for help if you're in doubt get help
such a great girl dad of course we all
know jlo's moved on so what do her
circle of friends think
jennifer lopez is a good friend of yours
she said to me that ben affleck was her
very first heartbreak we're about to get
married it didn't work out and it was
just a bad heartbreak how good does it
do your heart to see them together again
well i'm happy for her if she's happy
she looks very happy he's very happy she
legitimately something in her spirit
looks buoyed she looks very happy
jlo and gloria's friendship goes back
more than two decades estefan wrote
let's get loud jlo's 50th blowout
birthday bash was held at gloria and
emilio's miami mansion and yeah i think
it's safe to say jlo who told us she
believes in marriage even though hers
didn't work out looks to the estefan's
43-year union as couples goals you know
first of all we love and respect each
other a great deal he makes me laugh
every day in my life and he really
thinks about me like i woke on my
birthday and there's
a piece of paper goes hey don't forget i
love you forever and then the next day
for my anniversary i come back and
there's an another paper hi again
happy anniversary
again that's the kind of real talk
gloria emily and gloria's niece lily
dish out on red table talk the estefans
new episodes of their facebook watch
series return in december how often are
you having sex pero
do you think that's not as often as
before
i even surprised the crew that wasn't
aware of something that went down at the
table that i shared of course the og red
table talk is hosted by jada willow and
gami the table of passion the table of
truth what has been your favorite moment
of this journey the part about the whole
process that i cherish the most is just
getting to know the women in my life as
the individual women that they are
that's kind of how it started her asking
mom you know i want to know you and not
just you as my mother i was like
great
i got into a different kind of
entanglement
with august an entanglement there's been
so much healing
from marital entanglements to alcohol
and drug abuse and willow's polyamorous
lifestyle admission nothing has been off
the table for these women i'm the only
polyamorous person and i have the least
sex
out of all of my friends
and it is that authenticity which has
made red table talk a safe space stars
want to come to did you sleep with
tristan never
people have found this comfort zone
though with y'all how has that been i
think jada really sets the tone for that
100 but i tend to be
a little judgmental and i don't know
she's a boomer that's what we love
though because gary is that's why i like
the voice of the audience it's like
child police
no i get that yeah i do appreciate how
you got after olivia jade i do
appreciate that oh my goodness my god
you know games gonna come to the table
with the real reason he's coming with
all that fluff
the smith family invited e.t to their
jaw-dropping 150-acre lakeside estate
red table talk is filmed inside their 25
000 square foot home where are we right
now because the background is beautiful
it looks like an oasis this is gammy's
island
island is right there that's gammy's
island and her lake and this is
her
yeah well that's what mr smith says
he's the patriot he's a patriarch this
is my house jada this is his dream he
wanted all his kids to be able to live
here forever
we're like oh we should downsize no
we're getting older and then gammy and
will go nah
i had such a good time with those ladies
all right now let's move on to newlyweds
tarek el moussa and heather ray young
you know these two are definitely living
in style and our lauren zema got an
exclusive tour
can we talk about this headboard yeah
the pillow wall we wanted a lot of
velvet we just wanted to feel very sexy
i would say we're binge relaxers we'll
work 21 days straight and then we'll be
in this room yeah for two days
legit this is my favorite thing about
the house plays music
[Music]
i need a price point on the toilet
they're ten thousand each what was the
budget for this house oh we went way
over budget i mean i think originally i
think i would have to tell you we're
gonna spend like 400 000 i think we
spent almost a million bucks when it's
all said and done
tarek and heather paid just over three
million dollars for their newport beach
pad they've spent a year and another
million turning the three thousand
square foot digs into a moody glam
retreat and tarik's confident they could
flip it and sell for six million dollars
you're still working on the roof right
that's the final crown jewel and that
really made us like fall in love with
this house what do you guys see is that
next chapter is expanding the family
part of the conversation we just did
with a new puppy
she just started hinting at this like a
few weeks ago we have more kids we have
more kids